so this lecture is going to be on
reinforcement learning I will in
interest this time skip the quiz so so
the way to think about how reinforcement
learning fits into what we've done so
far is you remember this class has this
picture right so we talked about
different models and we talked about
different algorithms inference
algorithms to be able to predict using
these models and answer queries and then
we have learning which is how do you
actually learn these models right so
every type of model we go through we
have to kind of check the boxes for each
of these pieces so last lecture we
talked about Markov decision processes
this is a kind of a modeling framework
allows you to define models for example
for crossing volcanoes or playing dice
games or tram taking trams
what about inference so what do we have
here last time we just had value
iteration and which allows you to
compute the optimal policy and policy
evaluation which allows you to estimate
the value of a particular policy so
these are algorithms that operate on the
MVP right and we looked at these
algorithms last time so this lecture is
going to be about learning
I'll just put RL for now RL is not an
algorithm it's a kind of refers to the
family of algorithms that fits in this
week but that's a way you should think
about it RL allows you to either
explicitly or implicitly as to my MVP s
and then once you have that you can do
all these inference algorithms to figure
out what the optimal policy is okay so
just to review so what is the MVP the
clearest way remember to think about it
is it's in terms of a graph so you have
a set of states so in this dice game we
have in and n so we have a set of states
from every state you have a set of
actions coming out so in this case stay
and quit actions take you to chance
nodes where the you don't get to control
what happens but nature does and there's
randomness so out of these chance nodes
are transitions each transition takes
you into a state it has some probability
associated with it so two-thirds in this
case it also has some reward associated
with it which you pick up along the way
so naturally this has to be 1 3 4 and
remember the last time this was
probability 1/10 okay so and then there
is no the discount factor which gamma
which is a number between 0 & 1 tells
you how much you value the future for
default you can think about it as 1 for
simplicity okay so this is a Markov
decision process and what do you do with
one of these things we have a notion of
a policy and a policy
let's see I'll write it over here so a
policy denoted PI let me use screen so a
policy pi is a mapping from States to
action it tells you a policy when you
apply it says when I land here where
should I go should I do stay or quit if
I land well I mean this is kind of a
simple MVP otherwise it usually would be
more States and for every state blue
circle it will tell you where to go and
when you run a policy what happens you
get a path which I'm going to call an
episode so what do you do you start in
state s0 not so that would be in in this
particular example you take an action a1
let's say stay you get some reward in
this case it would be for you end up in
a new state oops s1 and suppose you go
back to n and then you take another
action maybe it's stay reward is for
again and and so on right
so this
sequence is a path or in RL speak it's
an episode
let's see so let me let me erase this
comment and so this is an episode and
until you hit the end state and what
happens out of an episode you can look
at a utility we're going to denote you
which is the discounted some of the
rewards along the way right so if you
you know stayed three times and then
went there you would have utility of
four plus four plus four plus four so
that would be sixteen okay so the last
lecture we didn't really work with the
episodes and their utility because we
were able to define set of recurrences
that computed the expected utility so
remember that we want to you know we
don't know what's going to happen so
there's a distribution and in order to
optimize something we have to turn it to
a number that's what expectation does so
there's two concepts that we had from
last time one is the value function of a
particular policy so V PI of S is the
expected utility if you follow PI from s
what does that mean that means if you
take a particular s so let's take in and
I put you there and you run the policy
so stay and you traverse this graph you
will have different utilities coming out
and the average of those is going to be
V PI of s similarly there's a Q value
expected utility if you first take an
action from state s and then fall pi so
what does that mean that means if I put
you on one of these read chance nodes
and you basically play out the game and
average the resulting utilities that you
get what number do you get okay and we
saw recurrences that related these two
so V PI of s is U recurrence the name of
game is two kind of Dell
to some kind of simple problem so you
first look up what you're supposed to do
in s that's pious and that takes you in
a chance node which is s comma PI R sub
s and then you say hey how much utility
am I going to get from that node and
similarly from the the chance nodes you
have to look at all the possible
successors the probability of going into
that successor of the immediate reward
that you get along the edge plus the
discounted reward of the kind of the
future when you end up in s prime okay
so any questions about this this is kind
of a review of Markov decision processes
from last time okay so now we're able to
do something different okay so if you
say goodbye to the transition and
rewards
that's called reinforcement learning so
remember Markov decision processes I
give you everything here and you just
have to find the optimal policy and now
I'm gonna make life difficult by not
even telling you what rewards and what
transitions you have to get okay so just
to give a kind of flavor of what that's
like let's play a game
so I'm gonna need a volunteer
I'll give you the game but this
volunteer you have to have a lot of grit
and persistence because this is not
gonna be an easy game he has to be one
of those people that even though you're
losing a lot you're still gonna not give
up okay so here's how the game works
so for each round R equals one two three
four or five six and so on you're just
gonna choose a or b red pill or blue
pill I guess and you you move to a new
state so the state is here and you get
some rewards which I'm gonna show here
okay and the state is five comma zero
that's an initial state okay so
everything clear about the rules of the
game
that's reinforcement learning all right
we don't know anything about how okay so
any volunteers how about you in the
front okay that's an empty piece so that
case I hope I warned you I'm glad this
worked because last time it took a lot
longer but you know so what did you have
to do I mean you don't know what you try
so you try a and B and then hopefully
you're building MVP and you're your head
right yeah right okay
just smile and nod and you have to
figure out how the game works right so
maybe you notice that hey a is no
decrementing and B is going up but then
there's this other bit that gets flipped
so can you figure this out in a process
you're also trying to maximize reward
which apparently I guess wasn't it
doesn't come until the very end because
it's a cruel game okay so how do we
gonna algorithm to kind of do this and
how do we think about cross doing this
so just to kind of make the contrast
between MVPs and reinforcement learning
sharper so Markov decision process is an
offline thing right so you already have
a mental model of how the work world
works that's the MVP that's all the
rewards in the transitions and the
states and actions and you have to find
a policy to collect maximum rewards
you have it all in your head so you just
kind of think really hard about you know
what is the best thing is I know if I do
this action and I'll go here and you
know look at the probabilities take the
max or whatever so reinforcement
learning is very different you don't
know how the world works so you can't
just sit there and think because
thinking isn't gonna help you figure out
how the world works so you have to just
go out and perform actions in the world
right and in doing so you hopefully
you'll learn something but also your
you'll get some rewards okay so since
maybe formalize the paradigm of RL so
you can think about as an agent that's
that's you and do you have the
environment which is everything else
that's not agent the agent takes actions
so that I sense action to the
environment an environment just sends
you back rewards and a new state and you
keep on doing this so what you have to
do is figure out first of all how am I
going to act if I'm in a particular
state s t minus one what action should I
choose okay so that's one one question
and then you're gonna get this reward
and observe a new state how what should
I do to update my mental model of the
world okay so these are the main two
questions I'm gonna talk first about how
to update the parameters and then later
in the lecture I'm gonna come back to
how do you actually go and you know
explore okay so I'm not gonna say much
here but you know in the context of
volcano crossing just to kind of think
through things every time you play the
game right you're gonna get some utility
so you take of so this is the episode
over here so ARS you're gonna sometimes
you you know fall into a pit sometimes
you go to a hut and based on these
experiences if I didn't hadn't told you
what any of the actions do and what's
the probability or anything how would
you kind of go about just kind of
solving this problem that's that's the
question okay so there's a bunch of
algorithms I think there's going to be
one two three four at least
our algorithms that we're gonna talk
about with different characteristics but
they're all gonna kind of build onto
each other in some way so the first
class of algorithms Monte Carlo methods
right so okay so when you're ever you're
doing RL or any sort of learning the
first thing you get is you just have
data let's let's suppose that you run
even a random policies you're just gonna
because in the beginning you don't know
any better so you're just gonna try
random actions and but in the process
you're gonna see hey I tried this action
and a lot to this reward and and so on
so in the concrete example just to make
things open more crisp it's going to
look something like in and then you take
you know you did let's see let me try to
color coordinate this so you're in n you
do stay and you get a free water four
and then you're back in in you do a stay
and then you get four and then maybe
you're done you're out okay so this is
an example episode just to make things
concrete so this is s 0 a 1 R 1 s 2 s 1
incrementing too quickly a - R - s - ok
ok so what should you do here all right
so any ideas model-based Monte Carlo so
if you have the MVP you would be done
but we don't have them be key we have
data so what can we do
yeah yeah let's try to build an MDP from
that data okay so the idea is estimated
MDP so intuitively we just need to
figure out what the transitions and
rewards are and when we're done right
so how do you do the transitions so the
transition says if I'm in state s and I
take action a what will happen I don't
know what will happen but let's see in
the data what happened so I can go look
at the number of times I went into a
particular s Prime and then divided over
a number of times I attempted any this
action from that state at all and just
take the ratio okay and for the rewards
this is actually fairly you know easy
when I because when I observe a reward
from s a and s Prime I just write it
down and say that's the reward okay okay
so on the concrete example what does
this look like so remember now here's mt
b graph I don't know what the the
transition distribution or the rewards
are so let's suppose I get this
trajectory what should I do
so I get stay stay stay stay and I'm out
okay
so first I can write down the rewards of
for here and then I can estimate the
probability of you know transitioning so
three out of four times I went back to N
one out of four times I went to N so I'm
gonna estimate this as 3/4 1/4 okay but
then I suppose I get a new data point so
I have stay stay and so what do I do
I can add to these counts so everything
is kind of cumulative so two more times
I started one more time I went into N
and another time I went to n so this
becomes 4 out of 6 2 out of 6 and
suppose I see another time when I just
go into n so I'm just gonna increment
this counter and now it's 3 out of 7 and
4 out of 7
ok so pretty pretty simple
okay so for reasons I'm not going to get
into this process actually you know
converges to the if you do this kind of
you know a million times you'll get
pretty accurate that question do we know
the number of states yes a question is
you don't know the rewards or the
transitions but yes you do know the set
of states and the actions set of states
I guess you don't know have to know them
all events but you have just observe
them as they come the actions you need
to know because you your agent and you
need to play the game yeah good question
okay so yeah so the question is does
this work with variable rewards and if
the reward is not a function of SAS
prime you would just take the average of
the rewards that you see yeah okay so so
what do you do with this so after you
ask them eight the MVP so you know you
needed a transitions and rewards then
now we have MVP in mind it may not be
the exact right MVP because this is
estimated from data so it's not gonna
match it exactly but nonetheless we
already have these tools from last time
you can do value iteration to compute
the optimal policy on it and then you
just you know you're done you run it on
in practice you were probably kind of
interleave the learning and the
optimization but for simplicity we can
think about as a two stage where you
gather a bunch of data you estimate the
MTP and then you are off okay there's
one problem here does you wanna know
what the problem might be you can
actually see it by looking on the slide
yeah well with your face policy of
always staying on never explore the wait
branch of the world yeah yeah you didn't
explore this at all so you actually
don't know how much reward is here maybe
like you know 100 right so so this is
this problem this kind of actually a
pretty big problem that unless you have
a policy that actually goes and covers
all the the states you just won't know
right and this is kind of natural
because there could always be you know a
lot of reward hiding under kind of one
state but unless you see it do you you
don't do just so no okay so this is a
kind of key idea key challenge I would
say in reinforcement learning is
exploration so you need to be able to
explore the state space this is
different from normal machine learning
where data just comes in passively and
you learn a nice function and then
you're you're done here you actually
have to figure out how to get the data
and that's that's kind of one of the the
key challenges of RL so we're gonna go
back to this this problem and I'm not
really going to try to solve it now um
for now you can just think about PI as a
random policy because a random policy
you eventually will just you know hit
everything for you know finite small
state spaces okay so okay so that's the
basically end of the first algorithm let
me just write this over here so
algorithms we have model-based Monte
Carlo and the model base is referring to
the fact that we're estimating a model
that in particular to MVP the Monte
Carlo part is just referring to the fact
that we're using samples to estimate a
model or you're basically applying the
policy multiple times and then
estimating the model based on averages
okay so so now I'm going to present a
different algorithm and it's called
model free
to call oh and you might from the name
guess what we might want to do is maybe
we don't have to estimate this small
okay and Wyatt why is that well what do
we do with this model what we did was we
you know presumably use value iteration
- you know compute the optimal policy
and they remember this recurrence for
computing Q OTT it's in terms of T and
reward but at the end of the day all you
need is Q opt if I told you Q oft si
which is what is aq opt si it's the the
maximum possible utility I could get if
I am in chance node si and I followed
often policy so clearly if I knew that
then I would just produce often policy
and our you've done I don't even need to
know understand the rewards and
transitions okay so with that insight is
model free learning which is that we're
just going to try to estimate Q opt you
know directly sometimes it can be a
little bit confusing what is meant by
model free so Q opt itself you can think
about it as a model but in the context
of MDPs and reinforcement learning
generally people when they say model
free refers to the fact that there's no
MDP model not that there's no model in
general okay so so we're not going to
get to Q opt yet
that'll come later in a lecture so let's
warm up a little bit so here's our data
staring at us remember let's look at a
related quantity so Q pi remember what Q
pi is Q PI of Si is the expected utility
if we start at s and you first take
action a and then follow a policy pi
right so in in I guess another way to
write this is if you are at a particular
time step T you can define you
t as the the discounted some of the
rewards from that point on which is you
know the reward immediately that you
would get plus a discounted pot and then
I'm next time sad plus you know squared
discounted and then to time steps in the
future and so on and what you can do is
you can try to estimate Q PI from this
utility right so this is the utility
that you get at a particular time step
so suppose you do the following so
suppose you average the utilities that
you get only on the time steps where I
was in a particular state s and I took
an action a ok so you have it let's
suppose you have a bunch of episodes
right so here pictorially let's see
here's another way to think about it so
I get a bunch of episodes I'm gonna do
some abstract drawing here so every time
you have you know si shows up here maybe
it shows up here maybe it shows up here
maybe it shows up here you're gonna look
at how much reward I get from that point
on how much reward I get from here on
how much reward do I get from here on
and average them right so and there's a
kind of a technicality which is that if
si appears here and it also appears
after it then I'm not going to count
that because I'm kind of if I do both
I'm kind of double counting in fact it
works both ways but just conceptually
it's easier to think about just taking
the NS a if the same you don't kind of
go back to the same you know s position
ok so let's do that on a concrete
example so Q PI let's just write it Q PI
as a is a thing where we're trying to
estimate and this is a value associated
with every chance node si so in
particular I've drawn it here I need a
value here and a value here okay so
suppose I get some data I say and then I
got go to the end so what's my utility
here
it's not a trick question
for yes some of for is for okay so now I
can say okay it's for that's my best
guess so far I mean I haven't seen
anything else maybe it's for so what
happens if I play the game again and I
get four four so what's the utility here
eight so then I update this to the
average of four and eight do it again I
get sixteen to deny average in the
sixteen okay and and again you know I'm
using stay so I don't learn anything
about this in practice you would
actually go explore this and figure out
how much utility is saying there so in
particular notice I'm not updating the
rewards nor the transitions because I'm
model free I just care about the Q
values that I get which are the values
that sit at the no it's not on the edges
okay so one caveat is that we are
estimating Q PI naught Q opt will
revisit this later
and another thing to kind of note is the
difference between what is called on
policy and off policy okay so in
reinforcement learning
you're always following some policy to
get around the world right and that's
generally called an exploration policy
or the control policy and then there's
usually some other thing that you're
trying to estimate usually the the value
of a particular policy and that policy
could be the same or could be different
so on policy means that we're estimating
the value of the policy that we're
following the generate data generate
policy our policy means that we're not
okay so so in particular is model free
Monte Carlo on policy or off policy it's
on policy because I'm estimating q pi
knock you opt okay that's on policy and
off policy what about model-based
Montecarlo I mean it's a little bit of a
slightly weird question but in
model-based monte-carlo we're following
some policy maybe even random policy but
we're estimating the transitions and
rewards and from that we can compute the
optimal policy so you can you can think
about is a off policy but you know
that's maybe not completely standard
okay so any questions about what model
free Monte Carlo is doing so let me just
actually write so what does the
model-based Monte College is doing it's
trying to estimate the the transition
and rewards and model 3 Monte Carlo is
trying to estimate the Q pi okay and
just as a note I put hats on any letter
that is supposed to be a quantity that's
estimated from data and that's what you
know statisticians do to differentiate
them between whenever IQ PI that's the
true value of that you know policy which
you know I don't have ok any questions
about model 3 Monte Carlo both of these
algorithms are pretty simple right you
just you know you look at the data and
you take averages yeah so question is
model free making changes to a policy or
as a fixed box so so this version I've
given you is only for a fixed policy the
general idea of model free as we'll see
you later
you can also optimize a policy okay so
so now what we're gonna do is we're
gonna do theme and variations on model
free Monte Carlo actually where it's
gonna be the same algorithm but I just
want to interpret it in kind of slightly
different ways that will help us
generalize it in the future yeah
problems where model three dozen
employees are there certain problems
where model free is better than
model-based so this is actually a really
interesting question right so you can
show that if your model is correct if
your model of the world is correct model
base is kind of the way to go because it
will be more sample efficient meaning
that you need fewer data points but it's
really hard to get the model correct in
the real world so recently especially
with neo deep reinforcement learning
people have gotten a lot of mileage by
just going model free because then jump
your head a little bit you can model
this as a kind of a deep neural network
and that gives you extraordinary
flexibility and power without having to
solve the hard problem of Noah
constructing the MDP okay so so there's
kind of three ways you can think about
this so the first we already talked
about it is you know this average idea
so we're just looking at the utilities
that you see whenever you counter in SNA
and you just average them okay so here
is an equivalent formulation and the way
it works is that for every si you that
you see so every time you see a
particular sau sau sau and so on I'm
going to perform the following update on
so I'm gonna take my existing value and
I'm going to do a what is called a
convex combination so you know 1 - ADA
and a - sum to 1 so it's you know kind
of balancing between two things
balancing between the old value that I
had and the the new utility that I saw
ok and the ADA is set to be 1 over a 1
plus the number of updates ok so let me
do a concrete example I think it'll make
this very clear what's what's going on
so suppose my data looks like this so I
hacked at 4 and then a 1 and a 1 so
these are the utilities right that's
that's a you hear I'm ignoring the SNA
I'm just gonna assume that there's some
something
okay so first let's assume that Q pi is
zero okay so the first time I do let's
see number of updates I haven't done
anything so it's 1 1 minus 0 so 0 times
0 plus 1 times 4 which is the first year
that comes in okay so this is 4 okay so
then that what about the next data point
that comes in so I'm gonna take 1/2 now
times 4 plus 1/2 times 1 which is a new
value that comes in and that is I'm
gonna write it as 4 plus 1 over 2
okay so now okay just to keep track of
things
this results in this this results in
this and then now we're running out of
space but hopefully I can so now on the
third one I do two thirds so I have 4
plus 1 over 2 times 2/3 plus actually I
guess I should do 2/3 to be consistent
2/3 times 4 plus 1 over 2 which is a
previous value that City and Q PI plus a
1/3 times 1 which is a new value and
that gives me 4 plus 1 plus 1 over 3
right so you can see what's going on
here is that you know each each time I
have this you know sum over all the
acuity I've seen over the number of
times occurs and this ADA is set so that
next time I kind of cancel out the old
account and I add the new count to the
denominator and it kind of all works out
so that and every time step what
actually is in Q PI is just the plain
average over all the numbers I've seen
before okay this is just kind of an
algebraic trick to get this original
formulation which is the notion of
average into this formulation which is a
notion of kind of you're trying to take
a little bit of the old
thing and add a little bit of a new
thing okay
so I guess I'm gonna call this I guess
combination
I guess so that's the second
interpretation there's a third
interpretation here which you can think
about is in terms of stochastic gradient
descent so this is actually a kind of a
simple algebraic manipulation so if you
look at this expression what is this so
you have 1 times Q pi so I'm going to
pull it out and put it down here and
then I'm gonna have minus a 2 times Q pi
that's this thing and then I also have
an ADA a u so I'm gonna put kind of -
you here and this is inside this print
so if you just you know do the algebra
you can see that these two are
equivalent so what's the point of this
right so where have you kind of seen
this before something like maybe not not
this exact expression but something like
it any ideas yeah when you looked at a
saccadic radius and in the context of
the square loss for linear regression
right so remember we had these updates
that all looked like kind of prediction
- Targa which was you know the residual
and that was used to kind of update so
one way to interpret this is this is
kind of implicitly trying to do
stochastic gradient descent on the
objective which is a squared loss on the
the q pi value that you you you're
trying to set and you which is the new
piece of data that you got so think
about in regression this is the Y this
is y you know the what the output is and
you this is the model that's trying to
predict it and you want those to be
close to each other
okay okay so so those are kind of three
views on basically this idea of
averaging or incremental updates okay so
it'll become clear why you know I did
this this isn't just to you know have
fun okay so now let's see an example of
model free Monte Carlo in action on this
the volcano game so remember here we
have as an example and I'm going to set
the number of episodes to let's say a
thousand let's see what happens
so here okay so what is this kind of a
grid like structure degree of triangles
denote so this remember is a state this
is 2 comma 1 so what i'm doing here is
dividing into four pieces which
corresponds to the four different action
so this triangle is 2 comma 1 north this
triangle is 2 comma 1 east and so on
okay so and the number here is the q pi
value that i'm estimating along the way
okay so the policy I'm using is a
complete random just move randomly and
I've run this a thousand times and we
see that the average utility is no minus
18 which is obviously not great okay but
this is an estimate of how well the
random policy is doing so you know as
advertised no random policy you would
expect to fall into a volcano quite
often okay
and you can run this and sometimes you
get slightly different results but you
know it's pretty much stable around
minus 19 - 18 ok any questions about
this before we move on to different
algorithms okay so model base Monte
Carlo were estimating the MVP lot of
free Monte Carlo we're just estimating a
Q
values of a particular policy for now
okay
so so let's really visit what model free
Monty Hall is doing so if you use a
policy PI eco stay for the dice game you
know you might get a bunch of different
trajectories that come out these are
possible episodes and each episode you
have a utility you know associated with
that and what model free Monte Carlo is
doing is it's using these utilities to
kind of update towards update uq pi
right so in particular like for example
this you're saying okay I'm in I'm in
the in state and I you know take an
action stay we know what will happen
well in this case I got you know 16 and
this case I got twelve and notice that
there's you know quite a bit of variance
so on average this actually does the
right thing right so um just by
definition this is our unbiased
you know estimate if you do this a
million times in average you're just
gonna get the right value which is
twelve in this case but the variance is
huge so if for example if you only do it
a few times you're not gonna get twelve
you might get something you know cited
so how can we kind of counteract all
this this variance so the key idea
behind what we're gonna call
bootstrapping is is that you know we
actually have you know some more
information here so we have this Q PI
that we're estimating along the way
right so so this view is saying okay
we're trying to estimate Q PI and then
we're going to try to basically regress
it against you know this data that we're
seeing but you know can we actually use
q pi itself to help you reduce the
variance so so the idea here is I'm
going to look at
although paces where I you know I
started in and I take stay I get a for
okay so I'm gonna say I get a for but
then after that point I'm actually just
going to substitute this 11 in okay this
is kind of weird right because normally
I would just see okay what would happen
but what happens is kind of random on
average is gonna be right but you know
on any given case I'm a kid like you
know 24 or something and the hope here
is that by using my current estimate
which isn't going to be right because if
I were they were right I would be done
but hopefully it's kind of somewhat
right and that will you know be no
better than using the the kind of the
raw roll out value yeah question yes the
question is would you update the furnace
after each episode yes so all these
algorithms I haven't been explicit about
it is that you see an episode you update
after you see it and then you get a new
episode and so on yeah sometimes you
would even update before you're done
with episode okay so let me show this
what this algorithm so this is a new
algorithm
it's called sarsa does anyone know why
it's called sarsa oh yeah right so if
you look at this it's bill starts up and
that's literally the reason why it's
called sarsa so what is this algorithm
say so you're in a state s you took
action a you've got a reward and then
you ended up in state s prime and then
you took another action a prime so for
every kind of quintuple that you see
you're gonna perform this update okay so
what is this update doing so this is the
convex combination remember that we saw
from before where you take a part of the
old value and then you try to merge them
with the new value
so what is the new value here this is
looking at just the immediate reward not
the full utility just a media reward
which is this for here and you're adding
the discount which is one for now of
your estimate and remember what is the
estimate trying to do
estimate is trying to be the expectation
of rewards that you will get in the
future so if this were actually coupon
occupy hat then this will actually just
be strictly no better because that would
be just reducing the variance but you
know of course this is not exactly right
there is bias so it's 11 not 12 but the
hope is that you know this is not you
know bias bite you know too much okay so
these would be the kind of the values
that you will be updating rather than
these kind of raw values here okay so
just to kind of compare them well okay
okay any questions about what sarsa is
doing before I move on so maybe I'll
write something to try to be helpful
here so Q PI Marquis Monticello
estimates Q PI based on you and sarsa is
still Q PI hat but it's based on reward
plus essentially Q PI hat I mean this is
not like a velvet expression but
hopefully it's some symbols that will
evoke the right memories okay so let's
discuss the difference is so this is
this whenever people say kind of
bootstrapping in the context of
reinforcement learning this is kind of
what they mean is that instead of using
you as the prediction target you're
using R plus Q PI and this is kind of
your pulling up yourself from your
bootstraps because you're trying to ask
me Q PI but you don't know Q pi by using
q pi two minutes
okay so us based on one path
in salsa your based on the estimate
which is based on all your previous kind
of experiences which means that this is
unbiased model free monitor colors bias
but sarsa is bias want to have has large
variance sarsa has you know smaller
variance and one I guess a consequence
of the way the algorithm set up is that
model fee Monte Carlo you have to kind
of roll out the entire game basically
play the game or the MVP until you reach
the terminal state and then you can now
you have your you to update where as
sarsa when or any sort of bootstrapping
algorithm you can just immediately
update because all you need to do is you
need to see this like a very local
window of SA RSA and then you can just
update and that can happen kind of you
know anywhere you don't have to wait
until the very end to get the value okay
so just as a quick sanity check which of
the following algorithms allows you to
estimate Q opt okay so model-based Monte
Carlo model free Monte Carlo or sarsa
okay so I'll give you maybe 10 seconds
to ponder this okay how many more many
more time okay let's get a report I
think I didn't reset it from last year
so this is includes last year's uh
participants so model-based Monte Carlo
allows you to get Q opt right because
once you have that me P you can get
whatever you want you can kick you up
motive free Monte Carlo estimates q pi
doesn't have to make you opt and sarsa
also has some it's q pi but doesn't has
to make you opt okay
all right so so that's a kind of a
problem like I mean these algorithms are
fine for estimating the value of a
policy but you really want the optimal
policy right in fact these can be used
to improve the policy as well because
you can do something called policy
improvement which I didn't talk about
once you have the Q values you can
define the new policy based on the Q
values but there's actually a kind of a
more direct way to do this okay so so
here's the kind of the way mental
framework you should have in your head
so there's two values Q PI and Q opt so
in MDPs we saw that policy evaluation
allows you to get Q PI value iteration
get allows you get a Q opt and now we're
doing reinforcement learning here we saw
a model free Monte Carlo in star sellout
you get Q PI and now we need I'm gonna
show you a new algorithm called Q
learning that allows you to get Q optin
so this gives you Q opt and it's based
on reward plus Q opt okay so this is
going to be very similar to sarsa it's
only gonna differ by essentially as you
might guess the same difference between
policy evaluation and value iteration
okay so it's helpful to go back to kind
of the MVP recurrences so even though
MVP recurrences can only apply when you
know the MVP for deriving and
reinforcement learning algorithms it's
they can kind of give you inspiration
for the actual algorithm okay so
remember a Q opt what is Q opt to the Q
opt is considering all possible
successors the probability immediate
reward plus future returns okay so the Q
learning is this actually really kind of
clever idea and it's it could also be
called czars stars I guess but maybe you
don't want to call it that
and what it does is as follows so this
has the same form the convex combination
of the old value and the the new value
right so what is the new value so if you
look at Q opt Q opt is looking at
different successors reward plus V opt
what we're gonna do is well we don't
have all we're not going to be able to
some of our successors because when our
reinforcement learning setting and we
only saw one particular successor so
let's just use that successor so on that
successor we're going to get the reward
so R is a stand-in for the actual reward
I mean is the stand-in for the reward
reward function and then you have gamma
times and then V opt I am going to
replace it with our estimate of what V
opt is and what should it be estimate of
V off to be so what relates V up to Q
opt yeah yeah exactly so you define V
off to be the max over all possible
actions of Q opto of s in that
particular action then this is V opt
right so Q is saying I'm in a chance
node how much what is optimal utility I
can get provided I took an action
clearly the best thing to do if you're
at a state is just choose action that
gives you the maximum Q value that you
get okay so that that's just no Q
learning so let's put it side-by-side
with sarsa okay so sarsa these two are
very similar
right so sarsa remember updates against
r plus a q pi and now we're updating
against our plus this max over Q opt
okay
and you can see that salsa requires
knowing what action I'm gonna take next
kind of a one step look ahead a prime
and it plugs it into here whereas Q
learning it doesn't matter what a you
took because I'm good just gonna take
the one that maximizes right so you can
see why salsa dip is estimating the
value of a policy because you know what
a prime shows up here is you know a
function of a policy and here I'm kind
of insulated from that because I'm just
taking the maximum overall actions this
is the same intuition as for value
iteration versus a policy evaluation
okay I'll pause here any questions
Q learning versus sarsa Q learning on
policy or off policy it's off policy
because I'm following whatever policy
I'm following and I you get to estimate
the value of the optimal policy which is
probably not the one I'm following how
they seem the beginning okay so let's
look at the example here so here's sarsa
and run for a thousand iterations and
like model free Monte Carlo this I'm
estimating that average the average
utility I'm getting is minus 20 and in
particularly the values I'm getting are
all very negative because this is Q PI
this is a policy I'm following which is
the random policy if I replace this with
Q what happens
so first notice that the average utility
is still minus 19 because I actually
haven't changed my exploration policy
I'm still doing random exploration well
yeah I'm still doing random exploration
but notice that the value the Q up
values are all around you know 20 right
and this is because the optimal policy
remember is just 2 and this is a slip
probability 0 so although policy is just
to go down here and get your 20 okay and
Q and I guess it's kind of interesting
that Q learning I'm just blindly
following the policy running you know
off off the cliff into the volcano all
the time
but you know I'm learning something and
I'm learning how to behave optimally
even though I'm not behaving optimally
and that's a kind of a hallmark of off
policy learning okay so any questions
about these four algorithms so model
based Monte Carlo estimate MVP model
free Monte Carlo estimate the Q value of
this policy based on the actual returns
that you get the actual sum of the
rewards sarsa is bootstrapping to
estimating the same thing but with kind
of a one step look ahead and Q learning
is like sarsa except for I'm estimating
the optimal instead of a fixed policy pi
yeah
Garza is on policy because I'm
estimating Q PI all right okay so now
let's talk about covering the unknown so
these are the algorithms so at this
point if I just hand you some data if I
told you here's a fixed policy here's
some data you can actually ask me all
these quantities but now there's a
question of exploration which we saw was
really important because if you don't
even even see all the states how can you
possibly act optimally so so which
exploration policy should you use so
here are kind of two extremes
so the first extreme is let's just set
the exploration policy so so imagine
we're doing Q learning now so you have
this Q opt estimate so it's not their
true Q Appa you have an estimate of Q
opt the naivety thing to do is just take
a use that kuat figure out which action
is best and just always do that action
okay so what happens when you do this is
you don't do very well so why don't you
do very well because initially well you
explore randomly
and soon you you find the two and once
you've found that two you say uh well
two is better than zero zero zero so I'm
just gonna keep on going down to the two
which is your all exploitation no
exploration right you don't realize you
that there's all this other stuff over
here so in the other direction we have
no exploitation all exploration here you
kind of have the opposite set up where
I'm running a q-learning right so as we
saw before I'm actually able to estimate
the the the Q opt values so I learn a
lot but the average utility which is the
actual utility I'm getting by playing
this game is pretty bad in pretty good
it's the you to you get from just you
know moving randomly so kind of what you
really want to do is balance you know
exploration exploitation so just kind of
a kind of a site or a commentary is that
I really feel reinforcement learning
kind of captures our life pretty well
because in life there's you know you
don't know what's going on you want to
get rewards you know you want to do well
and but at the same time time you have
to kind of learn about how the world
works so that you can kind of improve
your your policy so if you think about
going to restaurants or finding the
shortest path better way to get to to
school or to work or in research even
when you're trying to figure out a
problem you can work on the thing that
you know how to do and will definitely
work or you know do you try to do
something new in hopes of you learning
something but maybe it won't get you as
high reward
so hopefully reinforcement learning is I
know it's kind of a metaphor for life
anyways okay so back to concrete stuff
so here is one
you can balance exploration exploitation
right so it's called the epsilon greedy
policy and this assumes that you're
doing something like q-learning so you
have these Q up values and the idea is
that you know with probability 1 minus
epsilon where epsilon is let's say like
point 1 you're just gonna give exploit
we're just gonna do give you a give it
all you you have and then once in a
while you're just gonna do something
random okay so this is actually not a
bad policy to act in life so once in a
while maybe you should just do something
random and you kind of see what happens
so if you do this what do you get okay
so what I've done here is I've set
epsilon to be starting with 1 so 1 is
all exploration and then I'm going to
change the value a third of the way into
0.5 and then I'm gonna 2/3 of way I'm
going to change it to 0 okay so if I do
this then I actually estimate the values
really really well and also I get
utility which is you know pretty good
you know 32 okay and this is also kind
of something that happens as you get
older you tend to explore earth less and
explore it just happens ok alright so
that was exploration so let's put some
stuff on the board here do I need this
anymore
maybe this ok
[Applause]
okay so covering the unknown so we
talked about your exploration your
epsilon greedy and there's other ways to
do this epsilon greedy is just kind of a
simplest thing that actually you know
works remarkably you know well even the
state of our systems so the other
problem now I'm going to talk about is
you know generalization so remember when
we said exploration well if you don't
see a particular state then you don't
know what to do with this I mean think
about for a moment that's kind of
unreasonable because you know in life
you're never gonna be an exact same you
know situation and yet we are we need to
be able to act properly right so general
problem is at the state space that you
you might deal with in a kind of a
real-world situation is enormous
and there's no way you're going to go
track down every possible state okay so
this state space is actually not that
enormous but this is the biggest state
space I could draw on this on the screen
and you can see that this you know the
average utility is you're pretty bad
here okay so what can we do about this
so I guess let's talk about a large
state space so this is the problem so
now this is where the second the third
interpretation of model Fremont color
will come in handy so let's take a look
at q-learning okay so in the context of
SGD it looks like this right so it's a
kind of a gradient step where you take
the old value and you - ADA and
something that kind of looks like it
could be a gradient which is the
residual here so one thing to note is
that under the the kind of formulations
of a q-learning that I've talked about
so far this is what we call kind of roll
earning right which if we were you know
two weeks ago we were said this is
you know kind of ridiculous because it's
not really learning we're generalizing
at all right now it's basically for
every single state in action I have a
value if I have a difference in action
completely different value I don't I
don't there's no kind of sharing of
information and naturally if I do that I
can't generalize between states and
actions okay so here's the key idea that
will allow us to actually overcome this
so it's called function approximation in
the context of reinforcement learning in
normal machine learning it's just called
normal machine learning so the way it
works is this so we're going to define
this Q opt si it's not going to be a
lookup table it's going to depend on
some parameters here W and I'm going to
define this function to be W dot fee si
okay so I'm going to define this feature
vector very similar to how we did in
kind of machine in the machine learning
section like except for instead of si we
had X and now all the weights are going
to be kind of us you know saying okay so
what kind of features might you have you
might have for example features on you
know actions so these are indicator
features let's say hey maybe it's better
to go east than to go west or maybe it's
better to be in the fifth row or it's
good to be in a sixth column and you
know things like that so you have a
smaller set of features and you try to
use that to kind of generalize across I
know all the different states that you
might see so what this looks like is now
with the features is actually the same
as before except for now we have
something that really looks like you
know the machine learning of lectures is
that you take your weight vector and you
do an update of the residual times the
feature vector okay so how many of you
this looks familiar from linear
regression okay
all right so so just a contrast so
before we were just updating the Q opt
values but the residual is exactly the
same and there's nothing over here and
now what we're doing is we're updating
not the Q values we're updating the
weights the residual is the same and the
thing that connects the the Q values
with the the residual width or the
weights is the kind of a feature vector
okay as a sanity check this has the same
dimension this is a vector this is a
scalar this is a vector which has the
same dimensionality as W okay and if you
want to derive this you can actually
think about the implied objective
function as simply you know linear
regression you have a model that's
trying to predict a value from an input
si so si is like X and Q opt is like
kind of Y and then your record this
target is like the Y that you're trying
to predict and you're just trying to
make this prediction close to the target
yeah question yeah so a good question so
what is this a door now is it the same
as before or is it new so when we first
started talking about these algorithms
right ADA was supposed to be one over
the number of updates and so on but once
you get into the sgf form like this then
now this is just behaves as a step size
and you can tune it to your heart's
conduct all right so that's all I'll say
about these two challenges one is how do
you do exploration you can use epsilon
greedy which allows you to kind of
balance exploration with exploitation oh
and then the second thing is that for
large state spaces epsilon greedy isn't
going to cut it because you you're not
going to see all the states even if you
try really hard and you need something
like function approximation to
tell you about new states that you
fundamentally haven't seen before
okay so summary so far online learning
we're in the online setting this is the
game of reinforcement learning you have
to learn and take actions in real world
one of the key challenges is this
exploration exploitation trade-off we
saw for algorithms there's kind of two
key ideas here one is Monte Carlo which
is that from data alone you can
basically use averages to estimate
quantities that you care about for
example transitions rewards and Q values
and the second key idea is this
bootstrapping which shows up in salsa
and Q learning which is that you're
updating towards a target that depends
on your estimate of what you're trying
to predict not just the the kind of raw
data that you see okay so now I'm gonna
maybe step back a little bit and talk
about reinforcement learning in the
context of some kind of other things so
there's kind of two things that happen
when we went from binary classification
which was you know two weeks ago to
reinforcement learning now and it's
worth kind of decoupling there's two
things one is state and one is feedback
so the idea about partial feedback is
that you can only learn about actions
you take right I mean this is kind of
obvious in reinforcement learning if you
didn't don't quit in this game you never
know how much money you'll yoyo get and
the other idea is the notion of state
which is that you rewards depend on your
previous actions so if you're going
through a volcano you have to there's a
kind of a different situation depending
on where you are in in the map and
there's actually kind of so so this is
kind of a you can draw two by two grid
where you go from supervised learning
which is stateless and full feedback
right so there's no state every
iteration you just get in
new example and that doesn't have you
know there's no dependency and in terms
of prediction on the previous examples
and full feedback and because in
supervised learning you're told which is
the correct label even though there's
even if there might be you know a
thousand labels for example in image
classification you're just told which
ones a correct label and now in real for
still learning both of those are made
harder there's two other interesting
points so what is called multi armed
bandits is kind of a you can think about
as a warm-up to reinforce for learning
where there's partial feedback but
there's no state which makes it easier
and there's also you can get full
feedback by their state so in structure
prediction for example a machine
translation you're told what the
translation output should be but clearly
do actions depend on previous actions
because you know you can't just
translate words in isolation essentially
okay so one of the things I would just
mention very briefly is you know this
deeper reinforcement learning has been
you know very popular in recent years so
reinforce ammonia there was kind of a
lot of interest in the the kind of 90s
where a lot of the algorithms were kind
of in theory work um was kind of
developed and then there was a period
where kind of not that much not as much
happened and since I guess 2013 there's
been a revival of reinforcement of
research a lot of it's due to I guess at
the D mind where they published a paper
showing how they can do use robbery and
first morning to play Atari so this will
be talked about more in a section this
Friday but the basic idea of deep
reinforcement learning just to kind of
demystify things is that you're using a
neural network for cue opt essentially
that's what it is and there's also a lot
of tricks to make this kind of work
which are necessary when you're dealing
with enormous state spaces so what
of the things that's different about
deep reinforcement learning is that
people are much more ambitious about
handling problems where the state spaces
are kind of enormous so for this the
state is that just the you know the
pixels right so there's no huge number
of pixels and whereas before people were
kind of in what is known as a tabular
case which there's a number of states
you can kind of enumerate so there's a
lot of kind of details here to care
right one general comment is that
reinforcement learning is tech news it's
really hard right because of this
statefulness
and also the delayed feedback so just
when you're maybe thinking about final
projects I mean it's a really cool area
but you know don't underestimate how
much work and compute you need to do
some other things I won't have a time to
talk about is so far we've talked about
methods that try to estimate there the
cue function there's also a way to even
do without the cue function and just try
to estimate the policy directly that's
called you know methods like policy
gradient there's also methods like actor
critic that tried to combine of these
value based methods and policy based
methods these are used in deep minds
you know I'll forego and alpha0 programs
for you know crushing humans I go this
one actually will be deferred to next
week section because this is in the
context of games there's a bunch of
other applications you know you can fly
helicopters play backgammon this is
actually one of the early examples TD
gamma was one of early examples in there
the nineties up on they're kind of one
of success stories of using
reinforcement learning and particulars
you know self play for non games you
know reinforcement can be used to do
have later scheduling and managing data
centers and so on okay so that concludes
a section on Markov decision processes
which we the ideas that we are playing
against nature so nature is kind of
random but you know kind of neutral next
time we're going to play against an
opponent where they're out together
so we'll see about that